your feet into the discussion related to
the upcoming commission proposal on the
right to repair and more specifically to
look at how consumer rights and
guarantees can be strengthened to
promote the repair over other remedies
so
um
first
I would like to to ask our experts to
take the flow for maximum seven minutes
our our time is is limited 7 means seven
and then there will be two round of uh
of questions for two minutes each and in
the first rounds uh it will be
a question time for Epp snd and renew
and on the second round for greens uh ID
ECR and the left
so
um
I think we can start
so first I would like to to ask Anna
kaleko to take the floor she's director
General from the European commissioned
DG just please the floor is yours for
seven minutes
thank you very much good afternoon
honorable members ladies and gentlemen
I would like first to to thank you for
this opportunity to to have an exchange
with you on this important topic of
sustainable sustainable consumption of
goods I also want to thank you for the
resolution uh on the right to repair
that was prepared by the inco committee
and adopted in the European Parliament
plenary in April this year
now is a very timely moment to have this
important discussion as you know the
initiative on sustainable consumption of
goods promoting repair and reuse the
so-called right to repair initiative is
one of the key legislative initiatives
in the current Commission
we know that unsustainable consumption
of goods lead to unnecessary use of
resources and increased waste and CO2
emissions
based on the overall commission
objective of the green transition it was
announced in the commission work program
for 2022 that more repair and consumer
products will extend the useful life of
goods and therefore
further the circular economy
thus the commission largely shares the
concerns expressed in the recent
resolution of the parliament
the aspects are brought up in the
resolution delivered not only on the
European green deal but also on the
commission's overall strategy to fulfill
the United Nations 2030 agenda for
sustainable development
in its Preparatory work on the package
of proposals aiming at a more
sustainable consumption of goods the
commission has taken good note of the
three dimensions stressed in the
European parliament's resolution firstly
the products products need to be
designed to last longer and to be
repairable
secondly that consumers are empowered to
choose reputable products and thirdly
that consumers rights lead to a longer
use of goods the commission has tackled
these three dimensions covering both the
supply side and the demand side on the
issue in the three in three different
legislative initiatives first on the
supply side the commission adopted the
Eco design for sustainable products
regulation proposal in on the 30th of
March 2022
these proposal aims to extend the
lifetime of products so that it becomes
regular practice to design products that
are durable and fit for use for
refurbishment and for repair
secondly and on the demand side the
commission adopted a proposal for
directive on empowering consumers for
the green transition also on the same
day and which your committee is
currently working on
these proposal aims to provide consumers
with better information on durability
and repairability of products at the
point of sale so as to make informed
sustainable decisions
and thirdly also on the demand side in
the after sales context the commission
is currently working on the initiative
and the discussion here today to promote
sustainability of consumer goods in the
point in after
um after sale all these three
initiatives taken together will
contribute to a more sustainable
consumption
now the initiative on sustainable
consumption of goods aims to increase
the lifetime of repairable consumer
goods and to avoid the premature
disposal of this good
the commission may propose changes to
the legal guarantee framework regulated
in the sales of good directive in order
to promote repair over replacement
we may also propose instruments to make
repair more accessible and attractive
for consumers when the legal guarantee
no longer applies for example by
increasing transparency on the
conditions for repair
because the commission is following the
better regulation guidelines in the
preparation of the initiative and is
therefore working on an impact
assessment so as you would understand I
cannot be more specific on this point
right now but we still need a bit more
time to further improve our analysis to
ensure the high quality of the
initiative
as announced in the commission award
program for next year for 2023 the
initiative will be adopted in the first
months of 2023.
I am very pleased to see that the
European Parliament and the commission
are on the same wavelength length as
regards measures aiming at a more
sustainable consumption of goods
I therefore strongly count on on the
European Parliament to support the
commission proposals already being
discussed by the legislators as well as
well as the one that will follow early
next year and to deal with them in a
swift manner
it is important to pursue this common
goal of sustainable consumption we look
forward to to working closely with you
in this matter
unfortunately I will have to leave
shortly due to a very last minute
[Music]
important commitment but my colleague
Salah director for Civil Justice will be
happy to take to take questions and and
comments after the interventions of the
other experts I thank you very much for
your attention
thank you very much Ohana
before I will ask the next speaker to
take the floor I would like to say that
the best movie I have seen during the
last eight years was produced by bilk
it was about Geo blocking and how bad is
chair blocking so I now I would like to
ask Mr Ursula from Belk to take the
floor the floor is yours please
thank you very much chair for this kind
introduction and may I say the movie was
inspired by your legislative proposal
and your initiative and vision on this
respect thank you so much for that good
afternoon members of the European
Parliament ladies and gentlemen thank
you very much for having invited buke I
would like to start my presentation next
slide please with a short
um snapshot of what consumers think
about repair and how they feel about
that so I think it's important to notice
that according to a behavioral study of
the European commission consumers are
ready to pay more for more durable and
repairable products nearly 80 percent of
Europeans think that manufacturers
should be required to make it easier to
repair digital service digital devices
and to replace their individual parts
um according to the findings of a
project that we are running together
with other stakeholders which is called
prompt the most important barriers that
consumers face
when they want to repair their devices
are related to the price of repairs very
expensive the lack of good repair
infrastructure you don't find easily
good repair facilities and services and
the low availability of spare parts
there are a lot of other figures but we
don't have time to go through them but
just to pick some of the most important
messages I think about consumers for
this hearing today next slide please
so what is the right to repair I think
it's really important to see that this
is a horizontal objective and I think
it's just underlined by Mrs Gallego this
is not only consumer rights and consumer
contract law but it's really important
to foster a true culture of repair in
Europe and there is a lot of different
legislative areas that need to be looked
at and it's not only product legislation
and consumer law but I would like to add
maybe also intellectual property law we
just have a new proposal for a design
directive which is framing how long
design is protected in order to let
spare parts be produced by other
stakeholders not the right holders so
this is also an important element so the
proposal that is going to be is going to
be tabled in the first quarter now of
next year is only one piece of the
puzzle next slide please
so very very
um diverse are these elements that make
the right to repair so to speak we spoke
already about improving product design
which is the absolute necessary starting
point but we also need to take into
account the legal protection against for
example commercial practices that can
lead to early obsolescence we know that
information to Consumers about
repairability and durability is very
important the availability of the repair
information as such to Consumers but
also to repair services is essential
availability of spare parts and very
important longer legal guarantee periods
I just chose a few of these elements
next slide please
I skipped that one because I think Mrs
Gallego covered uh the state of play I
just wanted to underline one essential
Point here the sales of good directive
which basically is the framework for the
legal guarantees uh was revised not so
long ago and entered into application
only this year unfortunately it's really
a missed opportunity I have to say that
very clearly because basically what the
commission proposed and the legislators
then didn't go much further is a minimum
period of two years legal guarantee
period but we know that the legal
guarantee period which includes a right
to repair because if there is a lack of
Conformity consumers can ask for repair
that this is a very important point of
motivation also for producing
long-lasting products and it's probably
not the right approach that this is only
for two years next slide please
so these are our recommendations about
how to improve the framework for durable
and repairable products and consumer
rights in that respect because
durability and repairability they go
hand in hand
as I said two-year guarantee period is
insufficient for more durable products
we need longer guarantee periods and
that means a product specific mandatory
guarantee periods that should be
established we think that currently it's
really a very big opportunity with the
echo design being under revision what we
see is necessary is that there should be
a link between these product specific
rules that include repairability or
durability and they should be linked to
the civil law
consumer rights contract law framework
so these implementing measures of the
echo design directive they could be
taken into account when specifying how
long should the specific product related
guarantee periods last so that fridge
for example has a longer guarantee
period than a toy Etc so this is one of
our proposals next slide please
other proposals related to sales law
again is an extension of the reversal of
the burden of proof because we know that
for consumers it's very hard to
impossible to prove that there was a
defect when it comes to complex and
particularly also connected products so
this must be improved
second point is really important it's a
direct producer liability on top of the
Trader's responsibility we all know that
the current market realities are such
that it's not the trader who is uh in a
position to decide about the product
durability the design the repair
features of a product is not the trader
but according to sales law it is still
only the trader that is the reference
point and actually this is a demand of
Buick since more than 20 years that it
should also be the producer who becomes
liable in case of non-conformity other
more detailed measures to promote repair
within the hierarchy of remedies of the
sales proposal Mrs Gallego also referred
to that is that we think the so-called
proportionality test could be changed
and improved so that Traders cannot
easily refuse repair so if a consumer
says I think this is something that can
be repaired
uh it should not be easy for the Trader
to say well it's too costly for me I
cannot do it so we need to improve that
um excluding Replacements in case of
minor defects would be from our point of
view absolutely fair and acceptable this
is not the case for the time being but
we could accept that introducing an
obligation to carry out the repair
within a fixed time limit of 15 days
would help to make repair more
attractive for consumers because they
would know there cannot be an
everlasting repair and I will never get
my product back again if it's limited to
15 days for example
and in certain cases the consumer should
have a right to a replacement product so
that he's still or she still can go on
for example using a washing machine or
something else if there is a longer
repair expected and a last important
point which is again something that
links the green and the digital
transition it's about software updates
because we know that we will create a
lot of waste if we do not have software
updates because we need to establish
cyber security there is a total failure
in the market currently and now finally
commission has addressed it with the
recent cyber security resilience
proposal that is very good but updates
need to be provided for a certain amount
of time otherwise these connected
products will not be safe and many of
these items I am happy to say have been
included in the European Parliament in
this House's resolution that Mrs Gallego
mentioned of April 22 to on the right to
repair so it is very good and we call on
the European Parliament to keep up its
um its ambition and I think I can close
here because I know the chair is already
looking at me I would have had some
other points on product labeling but
they rather belong to the empowerment
proposal and have been already
proposed and there are very important
amendments pending from this committee
and I would just encourage you as
parliamentarians to keep up the ambition
thank you so much
thank you very much and next I would
like to ask Mr Pedro oliviera
uh from business Europe to take the
floor place the floor is yours
thank you thank you Mr chair
um and thanks to the European Parliament
for inviting business Europe to this
important debate and their honorable
members of this committee the ladies and
gentlemen
um business has been very supportive of
fostering sustainable consumption and
sustainable consumption is not only
about the product itself but also the
way it's produced its life cycle and
also the way it is procured or is
supplied so there's a lot of elements
into this equation so companies have no
choice whether or not they should be
sustainable but they have to be
sustainable because otherwise consumers
turn elsewhere to to buy their products
investors will not invest in them
shareholders will not be very happy
banks are not giving loans to companies
which are not sustainable nor are
insurers providing their services to
companies so this is definitely a trend
that that
um that needs to that that is essential
for for companies
now
in this context we have welcomed several
measures
stemming from the commission which will
improve the situation namely on the
sustainability on the production side on
the procurement procuring of and
managing of um of of of products and
components for companies
um there is the the sustainable Echo
design as we mentioned already the
empowering consumers as well the due
diligence because it's also an important
measure that has been proposed this year
also run by by director General
um Gallego on this and so there's a
combination of measures that are aimed
at tackling and and also enabling more
sustainability
now specifically on the repairability
of course it's uh it's very obvious that
if products can be repaired in the long
run we increase their longevity
we have more reduction of wastes
we also allow more use reuse
um and for return Goods they can also
become sellable via refurbished business
models they are also expanding so
there's a lot of positives
but sometimes I have the feeling we
forget we forget that since 20 years
when we're talking about these debates
since 20 years we have a right to repair
enshrined in new law so there is a right
to repair maybe we need some rebranding
of this discussion uh this came with the
sale of goods directive
and uh and uh it already entitles
consumers within the two years of
guarantee period to to have a repair
replacement of the other remedies uh at
its disposal
of course any
uh initiative that comes on top of of
this right that is already existing uh
needs to take into account some
trade-offs because one of them is of
course the circularity
uh safety as well because we cannot have
consumers uh sometimes having to repair
Goods that are dangerous to them because
some products involve chemicals involve
energy
electricity so this could be dangerous
for them and can put their safety In
Harm's Way
um
my colleague Ursula she mentioned
intellectual property rights so these
are also very important of course these
are one of the enablers of innovation in
Europe and watering these these down
would also put that stake our
competitiveness
we need to be able to look into the
alignment uh and to have some alignment
between all the initiatives that that
some of them I mentioned but all the
other ones that will come up uh soon so
it's important that we don't have
overlapping requirements
and
um also there is a question a trade-off
on the price because
Ursula mentioned that consumers are
willing to have more repairability
um but to which extent will they are
willing to pay the price because
there's other studies are there many
studies that also show that consumers
are not willing to pay more than 10
percent of the price of the products for
the repair
so there are some trade-offs that we
need to consider when we go for a
repairability initiative
in terms of principles for us for the
future initiative
the key words are the repair needs to be
safe
secure reliable and justifiable and
justifiable because repairability is not
should not be considered as an absolute
if it is not feasible or if it's
disproportionate because it can also be
unsustainable to keep prolonging the
life cycle of a product
then other options need also to be
considered
and we also
um need to have our consumers uh and us
I I'm also a consumer
um to be also be ready not to get rid of
the products uh when it's still working
because this is still happening
or when the repair option is put in
front of him that he prefers to go for
replacement so these also are things
that need to be taken into account
two remaining thoughts uh in the in the
remaining midnight and a half that I
have
one thought is on deserts
we risk having in Europe a manufacturing
desert
because with all the crisis that we're
having I'm not going to name them
because we all are aware of what is
happening we are recently having
companies either dislocating or stopping
production simply because they cannot
access
the the goods to to be able to
manufacture the prices of electricity
are five seven times more so it's
becoming very complicated for companies
to be able to have a breeding space to
continue to function and to survive
so it is very important that when we go
for new initiatives that we take into
account the timing
the proportionality and the
compatibility of all these measure
measures put together
and if a second and final thoughts
we also from the business side we get a
little bit confused about the
legislative process because if we look
at the draft report that is stemming
from this committee it is already
entering into the territory of the right
to repair uh that that the suppose
commission proposal will will cover so
there are many amendments that look
already covering this space so we are
wondering whether if we need a directive
from the commission because the
parliament is already taking this this
this forward so I stay here and very
happy to have an exchange on the all the
these these points thank you very much
thank you Pedro next I would like to ask
Mr Orla Butler from European
environmental Bureau to take the floor
please
thank you chairperson and thank you to
the committee and the organizers for
inviting us here today my name is oila
Butler I work on the circular economy
team at the European environmental
Bureau which is a founding member and
right and I'm Steering group member of
the writer repair Europe campaign and
next slide please
so to give an overview of the campaign
itself we are a coalition of European
organizations and businesses active
around the cause of repair in Europe
since 2019 we are based in several
European countries and we represent a
diverse range of stakeholders including
um environmental organizations
sustainable businesses and social
economy actors and any citizen who would
like to advocate for their right to
repair and as you can see with their
Steering group members along the bottom
this is a very diverse range of actors
all of whom have
the writer repair at the heart of RM
campaign and our movement is
overwritingly to make repair affordable
accessible and mainstream throughout
Europe next slide please
so there's so much at stake when it
comes to the writer repair and there's
so many different angles as and as we
have seen with the range of actors that
are interested in the campaign this
covers many different angles apart from
Simply the environmental benefits so for
example from the consumer perspective
using products for as long as possible
it leads to Consumer Savings in the long
term if price is indeed tackled through
legislation as we have discussed with
other panel members repairing brings
people closer to their to their devices
it boosts technological literacy and it
empowers remote communities who do not
have access to the manufacturers um
in the in larger cities and this desire
to for consumers to increase their
repairability is displayed by the fact
that 77 of EU consumers would rather
repair than buy new Goods of course
we've mentioned multiple times already
the environmental benefits that stem
from repair this is in line with the
European green deal the circular economy
action plan and the EU waste hierarchy
repairing overall leads to a more
efficient use of resources and reduces
the growth of E-Waste of which only 17
percent of E-Waste is recycled globally
which although this number is is
significantly higher in Europe
finally businesses are key to our
campaign and we really wish to promote
sustainable business models for example
by making repair easier through EU
policies this would create a competitive
market that does not exist today leading
to many local and local skilled jobs in
Europe as repairing cannot be outsourced
such as manufacturing that can come from
um for their field a good illustration
of the potential of repair and
refurbishing businesses would be our
campaign member swapby which was named
the fastest growing company in Europe in
2022 according to the financial times
so there really is so much at stake when
it comes to repair and so much potential
for us to tap into this sector that has
not yet been given enough
um opportunity
and the sustainable consumption of goods
promoting repair and reuse is part of
this a piece of the puzzle as and as we
have described there's a really holistic
need to approach repair through our
different policy instruments that I
don't need to go into again so on the
next slide I'd like to discuss
specifically the sustainable consumption
of goods initiative so within the legal
guarantee we recommend that repair
should be made to the primary remedy in
the case of non-conformity of a product
what's really important to us is that
Annie is that it's really clearly
defined when a repair or replacement
will take place and for any reason if
the product absolutely has to be
replaced all products should be returned
to the manufacturer and really really
put back into the socioeconomy loop
dismantled the Spy parts used to go back
into businesses refer repair refurbish
and make new products instead of going
to waste if they have been replaced
regarding the extension of the legal
guarantee as well as a policy option
um for this if repair is not made the
primary remedy
throughout the longer period of a
guarantee it's important that products
kind of continue to be replaced as they
are today and if the guarantee is
extended it should also still allow for
independent repairs to work on devices
and this extension of the guarantee
should not be the sole focus of this
initiative we really need to Foster
repair outside of the guarantee and then
this would also lead to increased
flexibility and options for consumers as
well as
creating competition with repair
businesses and independent businesses
next slide please
beyond the legal account is also a very
important time to promote repair for
this we recommend a separate polishery
instrument to be introduced for this to
allow a really to ensure that the the
issue is tackled correctly for example
consumers should always have a writer
repair solution whether that be through
repair Registries where they are
pointed towards a repair solution even
if it's outside the manufacturer's
Network this would again increase the
competition of local repair businesses
this is done through
increased access to spare parts and
repair information that should be
provided to the repairers so that they
can actually do a proper job on
repairing their products as of now it's
difficult to access information for
spare parts can be too expensive they
can be solely in the hands of the
manufacturer and so third-party spare
parts or second-hand spare parts must be
enabled to be used and this can still be
done in a very safe Manner and this
again creates opportunities for Market
solutions that aren't out there today
sorry my apologies
um so measures should finally be taken
to ensure the affordability of repair as
we did mention multiple times today it's
increasingly difficult for
um repairs to access affordable spare
parts that make sense for Community for
consumers to to go towards a repair
solution as opposed to
um
as opposed to Simply replacing one or
buying a new one and we recommend that
this is done through placing limitations
on the price of spare parts increasing
transparency with regards to the price
of spare parts and indeed making price a
Criterion of a European repair index and
when it does indeed come and the next
slide please
and so additional policy options are
also needed to prove to foster a
complete writer repair throughout Europe
beyond the legal guarantee as well for
this we recommend Financial incentives
to fully ensure their affordability of
repair and for this we can look to some
EU member states such as Austria and
Germany and who have introduced repair
vouchers and vat exemptions
um which is as is in the case in Sweden
another good practice uh with from a
national
um level would be the French repair
score index that includes price as a
price of spare parts as a Criterion of
the EU repairs of the French repair
score and this really enables consumers
to really choose what product is going
is going to
be repaired in the long term as price is
the main
um determinant and no choice of whether
or not to prepare or to replace
and finally if this legislation is to
truly be a safety net to ensure the
right to repair through certain
techniques that are barriers to repair
for independent repairs today this
includes Parts pairing which is a
software technique that is used from
that prevents repair outside the
manufacturer's Network as parts are
serialized to the overall device
um and then this practice should be
banned horizontally as it inhibits
independent and consumer in Planet
repairs and consumers from repairing
their products today and so the final
side please I'd just like to reiterate
that that we're very grateful to be here
today and to present this opportunity
for this great initiative we really hope
to see the initiative as soon as
possible as there has been some national
initiatives that have been put on hold
such as the German Action Program on
repair as we are waiting for this
proposal so thank you very much again
foreign
for your presentation I'm so sorry I I'm
putting you on the time pressure but by
all the speakers they have to respect
much more our interpreters than than me
with my rules
so uh
they are not able to
translate when
speakers are
speaking to to fast
so but thank you very much for your
presentation
our next speaker will be online from SME
United and
our speaker will be Guido Lena
uh with up the floor is yours
thank you very much chair and thank you
very much first of all today in Google
midi for the invitation next slide
please
I think I will repeat here a couple of
important messages from my previous
colleagues so it's important to if we
want to facilitate repair
to make it actually cheaper and easier
to be found on the market so either
through facilities for consumers like
vouchers as it was already said also
lower vat
it's also important that we keep
informing consumers of the current
rights that they already have and also
on the impact on the environment of the
choices so these I think it's a
fundamental issues if we want to start
to have a better repair in our society
next slide please
now for the legal instrument
um we think that
the new right to repair shouldn't
shouldn't be introduced through
amendments of the sale of good
directives these because these
directives as just come into force in
2002-22 so this year as it was already
said
smes have made a lot of investment
to comply with this deadline now if we
just push the deadline again if this is
going to cause uncertainty
um disrupt planning
this is what happens now regulate
European level that new deadlines are
constantly being introduced and these
delays investment
Made Company unsure and so this in the
end can be counterproductive
so it would be better if we use
instrument which have already been
proposed and mentioned like for example
Eco design or any way
um
no legal initiative to work consumers
next slide please
um now if we talk about the
possibilities that the online
consultation gave we are definitely in
favor of repairs primary remedy but also
to determine the repair as the consumer
remedy when it costs less or it's equal
to replacement
we are most capable about for example
um
longer guarantee period after repair
because it would means this would mean
that basically the guarantee would be
prolonged forever we know
predictability and also longer guarantee
periods for new and secondhand good for
different reasons one can be that the
trader
um the guarantee that actually the
trader gives to the consumer could be
different from the ones that the
manufacturers give to the trader so in
this case the trader would be exposed to
a period of time when he's got no
guarantee and he should buy new
guarantee on the market this would mean
that the price of of uh the product in
the office up becomes more expensive or
it doesn't offer this product any longer
so this would be a disadvantage for the
consumer the same goes for uh repair
products where is that there are a few
on the markets and so a part of the
population that would rely on repair
products would have lesser choice
and we are also totally against the idea
of
um extending the the guarantee framework
in cases where
um for example of normal wear and tear
or misantly of products by the consumer
itself we think that this would be a
huge uh burden on on manufacturers and
this this was also these Carriage
consumers behavior it's important that
we keep the responsibility in all the
supply chain including consumer and so
for some specific cases like these ones
there shouldn't be any specific
guarantee
next slide please
now it's a very important Point these
resources has already been mentioned is
repairs and particularly independent
repairs
they're Essentials for the right to
repair to be widespread and to guarantee
more competition and choice to Consumers
so in this case there should be they
should receive from manufacturers
all the information the software the
tools and the parts that they need to
repair and these in reasonable time and
also at fair price
and it's also there's also is a shortage
of skilled workers on the market and
member states should do something to
fill this in in order to not to hamper
on the a or And Delay the the repair
services in the EU
thank you next slide please
and there's also an issue of the right
to regress despite the fact that this is
allowed for the European legislation in
the end generally the final Traders
who's nobody in SME has very a lot of
difficulty to have the right to regress
from the manufacturers because it can be
another in another member states with
different implementation and there's
also these these proportional relations
between the big manufacturers and the
small Traders so in the end it would be
better if this right to regress would be
regulated better and more precisely at
European level with the same
implementation in all the member states
also to guarantee
um Traders which are in most cases smes
and also in this case
um
we have no problem with the direct
liability of supplier manufacturers
through claims under the legal
guarantees but the final seller should
not always be the the main point of
contact for consumers these should be an
advantage both for consumers which
doesn't have to track down the
manufacturers but also for the seller
because as an smes it's your advantage
to be known by your customers
and next slide please
so in a nutshell we definitely welcome
and we're in favor of the right to
repair it but this should be in a
certain way Fair balanced without
putting too much too many burdens on the
manufacturers and we have to be sure
that repair goes along with product
safety intellectual property and
liability as my colleague from business
Europe Pedro has already mentioned
so these were our main ideas and
proposals thank you very much and I'm
available for questions so discussion
thank you very much next I would like to
ask layout camps from generation climate
Europe to take the floor please
good afternoon everyone thank you from
all generations climate Europe for the
opportunity that has given us today to
speak in presence of this committee I am
like AMS I am collecting the
digitalization working group at GCE
this is the biggest Coalition of Youth
networks in the European level we
advocate for green and just transition
and we put intergenerational Justice at
the core of our work
more specifically in the digitalization
working group that I am colliding we
stand for youth involvement in European
policy making for the digital sector
the moment we are working on several
projects that concern sustainability of
softwares hardware and digital devices
and data management our fundamental
position is that we need to integrate a
circular economy approach on the digital
sectors in the past we have provided the
commission with several opinions on
initiatives such as the sustainable
products initiative the right to repair
initiative the digital product passport
among others
we want to start our speech by saying
that we welcome further initiatives by
the Parliament and the commission
to better integrate the circular economy
in digital sectors
in the circular economy that we want to
build on the future of Europe youth
involvement is fundamental
motivations to pay special attention to
youth in the U.S policy become even
stronger when digitalization comes into
play
we are the first generation to grow up
in a fully digitalized environment and
we are major consumers of Digital
Services as such the engagement of young
people is crucial if we want to achieve
both growth and sustainability and if we
want compliance and meaningful
implementation of the Norms impacting
design production and finally waste
management and recyclability
including health is important not just
for the present but also for the future
as to these youth will set the example
for what future Generations demand
shaping consumption patterns and
behaviors for years to come
the priorities of young consumers are to
have devices that are reliable and
durable at first and that can be
repaired affordably afterwards one of
the key solutions to the problem of a
waste is to increase lifespan of digital
devices a study by the European
environmental Bureau has proven that
extending the use of digital
Technologies by one more year and I
quote would save the EU as much carbon
emissions as taking 2 million cars off
the roads annually
by extending the life of your laptop for
example by two to four years can
decrease your carbon footprint by 50
percent
at DC we believe that the basis of
circularity in the digital sector
is the eco-design and sustainable design
at first
this is why we welcome the recent
sustainable products initiative in which
the new we could design regulation and
Echo design requirements are defined the
fact that the scope of products have has
been broadened including other products
besides energy related and the fact that
the initiatives tool cover the whole
life cycle of products makes it a good
start to put Echo design at the core of
circular economy efforts especially in
the digital sector
however when Echo design fails the right
to repair is fundamental here youth can
play a dual role it can be engaged in
the Reapers themselves and it can be
better informed on its consumer choices
to avoid unnecessary consumerism
good steps forward are already being
made with the commission's proposal for
the recast of the co-design directive
but more actions are needed in this
context we are suggesting including
youth as an activist stakeholder in the
future legislative initiatives regarding
the right to repair with dedicated
programs but also with explicit
references of Youth as stakeholders in
any further legislative outcome of the
initiative
youth can play an active role especially
in community and infrastructure building
and its digital competencies and skills
can be used to Foster youth employment
incentivizing an active role for young
people in the green transition is a
priority by making them part of the
construction and the management of for
instance workshops River cafes in order
to make Reapers easier accessible and
inclusive with the spare parts available
create jobs for small medium Enterprises
led by youth by developing and fostering
their digital skills and promote a
circular economy across all sectors of
society
to do so we need a strong focus on youth
to be included in any initiative that
might be taken in the future thank you
for your attention
thank you very much our next speaker is
representing French directorate general
for competition consumers and fraud
control
Helena Heron the floor is yours please
thank you
good afternoon everyone
the anti-waste legislation from February
2020 in France
allows us to respond to a number of
concerns
the sound level is very low The
Interpreter is struggling to to follow
but we'll do her best
we have a number of measures
on a number of different subjects
on the right to information
which was allow us to take action
against planned obsolescence of products
and combat waste
all right
we've got a list of repairs for electric
and electronic products
The Interpreter apologizes but the sound
level is insufficient for interpretation
and there's too much Distortion
um
[Music]
next slide
responsibilities
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
foreign
[Music]
next slide please
um
I apologize says the chair we're not
getting interpretation and the
interpreters reiterate that this is
because of the sound quality of the
speaker's connection
perhaps your connection is paused as the
chair
could you speak in English
so the the French law uh extend this
prohibition of planned obsolescence
um to to prove
to prevent the reparation of a tool or
to to try to to improve restoration
um
um
so in in France we we received three
three complaints uh since uh 2015.
so I mentioned just one of them a
complaint from Apple
um it deals with uh
it was in fact
um panel transaction uh concluded with
our French Ministry in 20 2020
um for uh 25 million euro
and in fact the consumer consumer
who who have a hyphen
they were not informed that's some
update of the system of their smartphone
will will lead to a kind of a slow
function months of their smartphone
so next slide
um so I will now present you uh some
information about the retail ability
indexed for electrical and electronical
products
so it's a very good information for the
consumer and this indexed until 10 is
put on the product
on on the sales
[Music]
please
um next slide please
so
um we had so five criteria
um
we are using to to Define
this uh this index in in France for uh
the documentation
uh is the fact that uh the producer uh
to give some information
to relate it to the reparation for the
consumer the second point is this
assembly in fact the heat of this
assembly and accessed tools and
fasteners
the third
aspects is the sparrow spots
availability and in fact the score is
established in relation to the
commitment of the producer on the
duration of the space part availability
and on the develop time
and then you have the price of spares
parts and some specific criterias are
also taken into accounts to Define in
fact a number and the number is used to
appreciate
this repellability index
and this index in fact was built with
the many stakeholders so manufacturers
distributorial consumer Association in
France and this index is now used on
nine types of electrical and
electronical products that are they are
mentioned on my slide
so I have different kind of of projects
and uh this uh this index is controlled
by the French administrations
uh if it's available at the point of
sales for example and if the
manufacturer is able to justify
the repellability index score and we
also put in place some really uh
specific control
so next slide
um so the concept of refurbished
projects which is a really specific
categories of projects in French
so next
uh thank you
um so the goal is to encourage the
development of this second earned Goods
Market
so I put the definition and there's a
French consumer account
um of this concept of refurbish products
so you you need
to to have done some tests regarding the
different functionabilities of the
product so and as a product as to to do
the correct purpose for which the
consumer requires this good and this
role a real necessity for us to clarify
this this concept and in 2020 for
example in France almost three millions
of smartphones
um which was a refurbished product I've
been sold in France
and next slide please
so maybe in the framework of the future
initiatives of the commission and repair
reparation
we can share with you some some proposal
and Reflections next slide please
um so the first one
is the legal guarantee period of
liability and the the fact to to
establish a kind of a unique
period of legal guarantee period for all
the kind of products the the neuron and
the second answered to
to remove the possibility for second and
second-hand Goods to to ever reduce
um
legal guarantee periods
the synonym proposal
is to to systematize
the reversal of the burden of proof
and to put it to two Euros
for the new projects
the the goal is to
uh to increase the reparations
in fact if you if you if you delete
the possibility
um
to reduce it to one year
and uh
more globally in fact the France and
courage all politics uh alluring are
more important repairability of product
in fact all the initiatives which lead
to
uh to reparation to refurbishment of
projects and then in fact we we need to
put in place
um a correct framework uh at European
living
um
it's important to to give some some
tools for the consumer
to deal with ecological Transitions and
um
we really need to
uh in fact um prohibit the
premature obsolescence
by the European rights and so we we are
in favor of all
this kind of politics uh allowing more
reparation and repairability in in
French
next line
hey it's Fini thank you and sorry for my
English because I really prepare my
presentation in French
thank you very much for that
presentation let's have just one round
of questions
first we will take all the questions and
and then our experts they they
will try to to reflect to respond so uh
first
in our speakers list is Thomas love
so-called from Epp group
thank you minutes please thank you very
thank you very much sir uh consumers
constantly contact me complaining that
their devices break down immediately
immediately after the legal guarantee
expires that the spare parts needed for
repair are not available and that repair
in addition to being time consuming is
often very expensive
most often they measure the breakdown of
mobile phones washing machines and other
household devices in addition they tell
me that the devices that their parents
or even grandparents used are still
working while the new ones are breaking
down faster and faster
on the other hand research has shown
that 77 of Youth citizens would rather
repair their devices than replace them
and in this regard European Parliament
has so far adopted two resolutions which
specifically asked the European
commission to propose an overall
legislative package that will solve the
problems with with product repair which
citizens face every day after we finally
managed to introduce common charger we
now have to fight for the right to
repair we want consumers to receive
information at the point of sale about
the expected durability and
repairability of the product to enable
them to make an informed purchasing
decision having said that first has the
European commission carried out an
impact assessment on right to repair and
are there any pro other problems apart
from the ones I mentioned the consumers
face when repairing the device
second does the European commission
applied to add practices that unduly
restrict the right to repair or lead to
obsolescence to Annex fund of the unfair
practice unfair commercial practices
directed and three what information does
Buick as the umbrella Organization for
Consumer Protection in the EU have on
planned product obsolescence the
consumers also report such practices to
you and what is your proposal for
solving the problem with planned product
obsolescence thank you
thank you Tommy sloth and the next
speaker will be online crystals from the
mosa please the four is yours please
thank you very much and I do hope that
you can hear me even though I'm on a
online anyway thank you very much for
all the presentations they have been
very very uh interesting and I think
that we realized that there is a very
big interest in in making a right to
repair and find ways to do it but also
of course looking into what we can do to
to do it workable also for the business
side so I mainly would like to ask
questions to the commission and so I I
hope that that goes even though
um with galigo has left first and
foremost
um I have to say that I'm sad that it
that we still haven't seen the proposal
but I'm happy to hear that it will come
in the first quarter of 23 however that
is real real relatively late if we we
would like to finalize the proposal
before end of this mandate secondly have
have you been considering for instance
the the link between the Eco design and
the durability and guarantee paired have
you consider been considering what to do
there and also this repair index
that we just heard about is that
something we could also have at the
European level I think that could be
interesting to know but but first and
foremost thank you everyone and I hope
that we will be able to deliver a right
to repair for for consumers and find a
way also to to at the same time help the
con the companies because I do believe
that in the long run this was will also
benefiting the con the companies thank
you very much
Crystal the next question is coming from
renew group Sandra the floor is yours
please thank you thank you thank you
chair I mean my main comment that we
have to really ensure a freedom of
choice
and right to repair the freedom of
choice and it is maybe maybe it is
mentioned in the in the in the legal
text but is not actually implemented for
no choice means that we shouldn't
exclude anything uh the right of a
consumer to buy a new product or to
replace it but we shouldn't even exclude
the minor replacement we have to really
ensure for a consumer the freedom to
choose and for this it is clear that new
intervention both legal and operational
intervention are needed the first my
first two question are to the commission
the first is how they will ensure a
coherence between the three texts which
are concerned you could design
empowering consumers and right to repair
and also I would like
um
to emphasize the need to accelerate the
presentation of the right to repair the
second the second the the other question
are to our expert how do they think we
should distribute the liability link to
the right of repair between the diff
different economic operator in the value
chain there is a need to distribute the
liability or not and if there is how
they should how they would would proceed
and the second question to our expert is
also linked to the last presentation the
commission is proposing a voluntary
labeling do our expert consider that
introducing a mandatory labeling link to
multi-criteria life cycle environmental
performance index might be more
efficient and more user-friendly for the
consumers thank you sir
thank you Sandra now I would like to ask
Anna kavatsini to take the floor please
contract where I'm actually representing
the committee at the conference of the
Czech presidency
so I think it's great that we have the
opportunity for this remote
participation because yeah like this
could follow the debate and all the
presentations the excellent
presentations for the stakeholders I'm
very very happy that
um all the stakeholders I think is here
our business as a committee that we need
um has a very incompassing and effective
right to prepare and thanks also to all
of you who refer to our resolution that
we worked on and what I find um really
really interesting
um and some of you mentioned it is and
the price question because I mean all
the other
um proposals we heard and be also
included in our resolution
um
have to be in the register here for me
is still not 100 clear how we can tackle
because
um
it is often because it's too expensive
or too expensive in relation to a new
product of course you cannot dictate the
prices
um this is completely clear then you can
also probably not do something on the
vat this is our national level but I
wonder
um is this idea that was proposed by one
of you
um that we really limit and the prices
of the share price is a way to go
um what I find also interesting um is
what the colleague from SME method said
and this is what I hear from a lot of
repairers and ending all over Europe
that's access to the information access
to
um yeah all the repair information for
the bigger companies is very crucial
that all the SES are the small repair
um tops they need access to the
um information about the bigger
companies otherwise they cannot repair
the product
um
yeah probably to elaborate more on how
we can achieve this and last question
um to the French representative
because it's that you planned already
um you banned already plenty of sense
um I would be interested if you could go
a little bit more into these
Tales explaining how this exactly is
working because
um of course I'm getting told by some
companies it's very uh difficult to
prove what is really a plan of solar
sense how do you exactly regulate this
in France experience
thank you very much and now I would like
to ask does somebody who is representing
the ID group to take the floor
now I can't see
the same question about DCR
he's here somebody representing ECR who
wants to take the Vlog
no once again then I would like to ask
uh Sophie Pelletier to take the floor
please
merciful
thank you very much Mr chairman
thank you so much to all the speakers
for those very interesting and crucial
presentations and thank you all for
being here I'm very pleased about what
we're discussing at this table round
which I feel very strongly about it
reparation is a way of reducing our
consumption and reducing waste and so
nonetheless instead of being a reflex
the consumer's First Choice is not
necessary to resort to reparation nor is
it encouraged by companies we're going
to have to rethink about all of our
capitalist economic model which has a
huge impact on consumers and protection
of the planning pushing companies to
want more and more Pro profit and adapt
marketing message which are aggressive
and the consumers have to buy new
products rather than repair them and
they don't always have enough
information when purchasing their
products and they're not informed about
their rights and as was previous
stressed in inkel we voted on a
resolution motion to for the right to
reparation which our president Anna
brought it was very ambitious text
hopefully to reorient the commission's
work and lead to concrete proposals that
text to say that 79 of the consumers
think that manufacturers should make
product reparation easier and we're
replacing of digital products and only
17 percent wanted to keep the
possibility replacing but the right to
repair is very important and therefore
manufacturers and Traders must provide
clear reliable accessible and
comprehensible information before
purchase to
guarantees sustainability we've got to
be able to say how long the product is
to last and
planned obsolescence is a huge Scourge
and we must be able to get rid of this
in a harmonized way and we've got to
fight these expensive reparations
consumers must have all the information
they need on reparation services and the
spared Parts they must be easy to find
and must be sold at affordable prices
now if repairing your product costs more
than buying a new one you're not going
to choose repair and therefore we have
been pushing consumers toward that
choice for better transition and
planning I hope the commission will take
on more of these elements to enrich
their proposals on consumers right and I
to finish I'd like to thank Mrs ihorn
for her presentation the English
presentation it was not easy it was not
always easy when you're asked to speak
English thank you for being so adaptable
and I'd like to know what kind of room
for maneuver uh the national authorities
have to force the companies to meet
their obligations with respect to
product planned obsolescence and how can
we act to detect this product and uh
prove that voluntary obsolescence is
actually inherent to the product thank
you I'd like to ask for is somebody here
in the room waiting for catch the eye
time
to raise questions no one then
let's take the same order uh as uh as
you know first rounds for experts and I
would like to ask
Miss uh
Salas from the European commission to
take the floor please
foreign
thank you chair and thank you to The
Honorable members of those uh questions
and observations and I also appreciate
to hear all the other experts in this
first round uh I think that the
questions bring a quite much uh to the
attention that we are dealing in the uh
area where we have several pieces of
legislation where we aim to make a
coherent uh coherent framework to
promote the right to repair to promote
the circular economy for example the
early obsolescence that was raised by
The Honorable members that is dealt with
by the empowering consumers initiative
which is amending the unfair unfair
consumers uh commercial practice is
directive to tackle this type of the
practices
or then there was a question about the
link to echo design Echo design
legislation and indeed the econ design
alleged isolation will look at the
product a design phase the we are
closing then the remaining caps with the
future proposals for example the closing
those gaps that are there on the after
sales phase so we have to we are really
aiming to ensure coherence with these uh
existing legislation those proposals
that are on the table and then with the
future proposal
um there was uh there was a question
that whether there is the impact
assessment indeed the impact assessment
process is going on and uh we I we I I
heard today about the difficulties that
the uh that the consumers and have been
um has met including inconveniencies in
the repair process and this is all that
we are now then aiming to take into
account in our proposal these
inconveniences they can relate to the
lacking information
or then to the price and what we try to
bring there is to have more transparency
for example quotes on the price so that
there's information and make it make it
easier to compare than the offers so
that type of the competitive uh approach
also within the repair services is the
part that we need to bring uh forward uh
mentioning mentioning about the
repairability or the European label for
the repair ability then I go back a
little bit to this Echo design
legislation which is already bringing
certain rules under certain product
groups so those it comes by then a group
by group or sector by sector uh possibly
they're starting with the smartphones
and tablets so this is this is a coming
from the uh one one perspective so maybe
this type of the ask is also remembering
the coherence and that we are indeed
then aiming to take into account this
comments we have received a lot also
through the public consultation round
that we are carrying is part of the part
of the impact assessment but my final
reassurance is that the process is
advancing well inside of the commission
and we are indeed aiming for the
proposal to be there in the beginning of
next year thank you
thank you
next up
from Belk the flow is yours please yes
thank you very much chair
um I'd like to respond first of all to
the question of premature of solar sense
I think it was Mr Sokol who asked uh the
question was whether we have evidence
about premature obsolescence and I think
I mentioned in the beginning of my
presentation that we have a project
which is called prompt project which is
exactly testing products and Gathering
complaints from European consumers in
several countries and what we can
conclude from there is definitely what
you mentioned what consumers report to
you is also what our members experience
namely that products today they do not
last very long often and that they
seemingly are not as durable as
potentially they used to be in the past
so it is very important to address this
problem we heard the European commission
and indeed have already addressed the
problem to a certain extent in the
empowerment Proposal with a listing six
practices that should be banned we would
like to go a step further so this is
also a call on the European Parliament
to be more ambitious because we need to
have a General ban on the practice of
premature Solutions not only on not
informing consumers about the fact that
this may be a product that does not last
because this is currently what the
unfair commercial practices holds is
about informing consumers correctly and
if you don't you mislead and then it's
prohibited but we want the practice as
such to put these type of products on
the market that must be prohibited I
think this is very important and there
is no
um I mean there does not need to there
should not be intent that is required
because this is also one of the problems
that this is not something that must be
planned obsolescence it must be simply
premature obsolescence that must be
banned I mean we have a position paper
with all specific details of what needs
to be changed in the empowerment
proposals and I would be happy to share
that link is also in our presentation at
the very end of the presentation
uh secondly uh in terms of uh the price
I think it was Mrs cavacini asking for
that let me make one point which I think
is fundamentally important
if we do not increase the durability in
terms of giving the consumers the right
to it through the legal guarantee
proposal we will just have two years of
guarantee for everybody for all products
and if the product fails after two years
consumers will have to pay for the
repair but what would be fair and just
would be that the real guarantee period
is expanded for durable products and in
that durable guarantee period consumers
have a right to a free repair and this
is the only way how we really can make a
difference with uh promoting repair it
should not be at the bottom at the at
the back of consumers that we promote
repair right to repair must come with a
better legal guarantee period this is
just a fundamental
issue that I would like to put on your
radar and the price of repair indeed
that is something that we must be
carefully consider we think that with
making repair more accessible making
information more accessible with
consumers having a very quality repair
in their closure environment they should
be able also to bring down the prices
but of course intellectual property
rights make also a big part of that the
liability joint liability also for
repair of course within the legal
guarantee framework that would mean the
producer is also responsible if the
consumer chooses and I underline the
consumer must choose to go for repair
and then I would like to underline also
what Mrs chalde Mose asked about it's
really time and I would again encourage
the commission to make that step to link
the echo design requirements to the
consumer rights for example we are
asking also for remedies for consumers
in case Echo design requirements are not
met that is just a very logical step to
make cake and it will help to
incentivize the market players to
deliver durable products thank you very
much
thank you very much
some members asked during the meeting
about what kind of movie we were talking
about an hour ago
you can easily find this video clip from
YouTube typing Belk and stop geoblocking
okay waiting for new movies
uh next I would like to ask Pedro
Oliveira from business Europe to take
the floor thank you thank you Mr chair
and I hope that business Europe one day
will become eligible as well for the
Oscars of the best clip or the best
movies uh we at least my communications
department works very hard on it
um there were no really questions
addressed to to business Europe
specifically but just to focus on a few
points that have been raised by The
Honorable members of this committee
um there was a fundamental question
about how do we assess then the
liability on the right to repair because
if we want to make it open to anyone
including the consumers and even
non-agree non-certified repairs then the
liability that needs to be shifted and
then this is the whole kind of worms
that needs to be opened and and it's not
going to be easy to to assess to assess
this
um
on having I I heard about the
possibility of having a a label that
includes a lot of information
um around life cycle around
sustainability around all the sorts of
things of course it's the Eternal
discussion to have one single
um one single label that captures
everything of course this represents a
lot of
um
problems or or challenges because some
of the information might be confusing
contradictory
um to verify it to enforce it to read
and understand it will become quite a
big challenge but of course the
multiplication of labels that we see in
Europe nowadays is also problematic so I
think some some the answer must be
somewhere in the middle
on limiting prices on spare parts as I
mentioned in my intervention companies
are already under extreme difficult
circumstances right now with seven times
that they have to pay more for their
electricity prices value chains are in
shutters nowadays and of course we have
new legislation that is coming one of
the legislation is being treated by this
committee the the forced labor ban and
uh and also the due diligence and on
both case occasions companies will be
forced to decouple will be first to cut
on primary materials to be able to
produce even or even to access those uh
those spare parts so at the end of the
day this is all will be also about
trade-offs that we will need to come to
terms with
um then also to
and make a distinction it's important to
make a distinction between the
um the the legal guarantee and and the
repairability because legal guarantee I
mean even the commission was doing its
uh Fitness check a few years ago and it
discovered that most of the problems
occur in the first six months uh that
from a buying of a product this is in 70
percent of the cases and up to the first
year 90 so we need to be clear what we
are talking about here
um because repairability repairability
is about the service and Beyond the
legal guarantee of course there this
should be encouraged and we should find
the best solutions to to to to to make
it accessible but of course this needs
to be done with some balance and then
final word about courage
this committee is the champion of the
internal Market
and we've been witnessing seeing a lot
of problems in the in the last years
that we go for minimum organization
directives on a lot of fields you had
the courage I mean I look at Mr arimon
who championed the sale of goods
directive and it was possible to keep
the full harmonization approach and we
hope that this is guaranteed not only on
the right to repair but on other
initiatives that will stem still within
this
um this legislature term so for us for
the business side it's very important to
fight fragmentation and to keep the
internal Market intact thank you very
much
thank you I would like to ask Miss Orla
Butler from European environmental
abroad now to take the floor please
thank you very much
the concerns that were expressed by
members regarding the delays of this
initiative but we do really hope that
this does Ensure coherence with the
other legislations that are coming in so
we hope that it will be indeed worth the
wait in the end
regarding the questions on premature
after lessons indeed it is difficult to
prove that this is a practice that is in
place at the moment but what we believe
is that your writer repair staffs where
the manufacturer is right to make an
unrepairable product takes place and so
as long as this is allowed as long as
you don't have the access at the right
to the repair information there's spare
parts Etc and you don't entirely have
the right to repair and so indeed the
obsolescence will be regulated for in
the upcoming empowering the consumers
through the green transition and we
really hope that this is banned outright
as opposed to currently being an
information requirement that these
practices are taking place as we think
that they should not be permissible in
any in any way with regards to the
question on the price we've believed
that there's a fundamental problem with
the market if indeed replacing a good
with an entirely new product is cheaper
and more affordable for consumers than
to repair the price than to repair um
the product this as I said should be
tackled the prices by Parts really does
need to be tackled and it should be done
through placing um the price of spare
parts as a Criterion of the repair index
and there was a mention towards the
smartphones and tablets
um a label a probability label that was
unveiled which we really welcome but
however we do regret the mess
opportunity that the prices per Parts
was not included and so it will be
difficult to foresee that this will
really be a determining factor in in a
consumer's choice of whether to repair
or to replace
um overall I'd just like to finish
because I'm conscious of time and I'm
aware that other panelists still have
yet to respond that we do need increased
information increased and support to to
repair businesses and we are very
conscious of all the different actors
that are involved and so again I'd like
to thank you so much for your
participation today and I'd like to move
on to the next panelist thank you
thank you very much next I would like to
ask Mr Leia camps to take the floor
please
yeah so the so there were no really
questions addressed to GC but just some
bullet ones uh
it's been said it's important to inform
consumers uh across all sectors of
society
labeling also it's it has to be easily
accessible and better it has to be clear
for consumers to understand it and to
enable them to make better choices and
also just state that it's important to
include youth at any point of European
legislation
thank you
thank you next I would like to ask
Mr Guido Leonard from SME United to take
the Vlog he is still connected online
thank you chair yes first of all
um a couple of words on liability for
manufacturers I think that
um there are clear cases where
manufacturers cannot be liable for
example if a consumer mishandled the
product if I take my mobile phone I'll
throw it against the wall or I drop it
in the toilet I cannot ask the product
to be repaired for free or replaced the
same goes for I think normal wear and
tear once the years the guarantee have
passed the legal guarantee and the
product
which not sub which is not subject to
premature of solar sense
static giving problems either I repair
it myself with my money or I buy a new
one it's it's impossible to overburden
the manufacturers constantly with new
requirements with already all the
burdens that
are on them in the current situation and
it's a matter also fairness uh everybody
in the society takes a share of
responsibility and labels we if in case
of of a label for example for the
reparative ability index we would be
in favor of having linked together
integrated into added into the energy
labels because in most cases the
probability index we've seen in France
it deals with products which have
already a sort of energy label and
having one or linked to the two would be
also would mean less confusion for the
focus for the consumers and also less
and fewer uh bureaucracy and rate tape
for the manufacturers
and for repairs in the end there was a
question for Mrs cavatsini and I can
only reiterate that giving to
Independent repairs the tools in any
case to perform the repair the repair is
essential and if it's the case it should
also be introduced through through
specific rights otherwise the whole
thing we will not work thank you
thank you very much and now Helena
the floor is yours please
Central
maybe just a few comments first of all
regarding the question of uh and plan
plan obsolescence yes in France it's
forbidden since
2015 and we have reinforced it in 2020
for sure it's not easy to to do the
demonstration but we have an ongoing
investigation on this issue
um we consider in France that uh yes
it's not sufficient to demand a correct
uh information of the consumer regarding
the practices of unplanned unplanned
obsolescence it's important to to prove
it these practices and maybe a last
point to conclude regarding the legal
guarantee period of liability
we considered a good idea to try to
increase it for some kind of products
for example major appliances until for
example three years
thank you very much
I would like to call the other thank all
our experts called the speakers uh
I'm I'm sure we got much better
understanding what the right to repair
for early means and what we as
legislators have to do to guarantee this
right to our people thank you very much
and now we can move to our agenda Point
number seven
corporate sustainability due diligence
and diamantic directive
2019 1937
a reporter for the opinion Miss
Clune from Epp consideration of
compromise amendments so now I would
like to ask our reporter to take the
floor